so 64
of people say the economy is worse than
it was a year ago well no kidding 76
percent of democrats say the economy is
worse only 50
republicans say the economy is worse and
there's been a debate about a k-shaped
recovery the kind of
recession uh is characterized by the
fortunes of workers that go into one or
two directions the first segment of the
population has its prospects
recover from a downturn almost
immediately and another suffers much
longer the differences between the rich
and the poor
do you think the wealth gap is getting
wider
during the coronavirus did this thing
make it wider or not at all without a
doubt that's without a doubt that's
where
jay powell and his happy printing press
come in so the biggest companies have
been bailed out
companies that should have gone out of
business it's called creative
destruction you get rid of the
unprofitable
inefficient operators you make room for
the new entrance it's the way
productivity grows
but we haven't done that instead we've
kept all the businesses that are big and
have access to the capital markets
access to high-yield bonds junk bonds
we've kept all of them in business
he's kept a stock market at all-time
highs so that
the wealth that the 55 percent of
americans who own stocks they're feeling
awesome
and he's also bought up a third of
mortgages he owns a third of the
mortgage market
that goes a long way towards giving you
a 2.96
30-year conventional mortgage rate so
americans who have built up
record levels of equity in their homes
have pulled a hundred billion dollars
out in home equity in the past six
months alone and it's september 30.
a hundred billion dollars of cash so if
you own a home and if you own stocks
you're feeling awesome you are living
the dream
if you don't you have a whole different
perspective
on life in america hmm that's what they
talked about this k
shape that's exactly right so initially
they were talking about it's going to be
a v-shape recovery right it's gonna it's
gonna well for the top it's the top of
the cake
it is a v okay and for the bottom you
took the k and you put it into a v
that's good
but that's the thing the top the top of
the k some industries do well sorry but
the other ones don't well they were
thrown out the top of the k applies
a u-shaped recovery right it was going
to take a bit longer than i was talking
about
worst case scenario was there's an
l-shaped recovery right if we
if we don't i don't know if it's halves
and half's knots i think it's industry
no but if if again 55 of americans own
stocks
so the other 45 percent are not enjoying
the fruits of stocks being at all so
what's the solution
what's the solution if the other 45 or
not again we have to
enable people to live the dream
you're an entrepreneur right you've
brought lots of young employees on in
your time
i did but 95 percent of them quit
well i can't i can't do what i'm we're
surrounded by young people
what i'm saying is on the sales side no
no what i'm saying on the sales side so
here's a challenge so so let's talk
about it pretty theory are you familiar
with the pareto theory
the pareto theory is that eighty percent
of work is going to get done by twenty
percent
this is not a new 80 20 80 20 rule
applies in sports if you
yesterday steve uh uh davis scored 34
points
and you know he's the guy that's scoring
the most points lebron james teammate
ever 28.8 points a game
no one's ever okay you know 80 of points
were scored by 20
of guys pretty much if you look at that
number it's not the you know
you see the few produced on the most so
then
the the challenge with this concept of
the rich getting richer the poor getting
poorer
i have a challenge with that and here's
my challenge with that
if if the challenge is to crucify the
guys that made the right decision to
invest
and the guys didn't why are we saying
the guys that
are making money are bad people they're
making money because they stayed in the
market they're not bad people but the
people who don't own stocks
surely they don't have they're getting
buying credit cards
they don't have any money to invest i
know what it is to be in that situation
my dad was a cashier at a 99 cent store
i mean i
parents got a divorce i was 49 k dead at
22 years old
i get it i had the option to go to vegas
every other weekend and party or i had
the option to save money i hated saving
money so let me ask you a question
do you think that the 80 20 rule applied
a few generations ago
or do you think something has happened
to the work ethic because we've given
a generation of children you know you
know this is sorry sorry boy but
that we've that we've given an entire
generation of children she's glad you
referred to
the children everything that they wanted
time magazine did an article
six years ago titled you know how
millennials are becoming narcissists
right
all they care about is themselves and
all this other stuff and you read the
article says oh millennials are this
millennials are that they want to take
pictures of themselves
they think they're so important they
think they're this they think they're
that you know how the article
ended the article ended if
or here's how it says the article says
or
if we are the ones that are making fun
of millennials
for only thinking about themselves maybe
we're just getting older
and we forgot how we used to be so what
i'm trying to say is
that story about when i was younger i
was growing and going to
school and it was snowing and it was a
mountain both ways you know this whole
story you hear about it
so so i think times have been hard i
think obviously it's been harder than
what it is today today is easier than
it's ever been before they had their
coming of age in the middle of a
financial crisis
i mean i do think it's easier today ever
before to make money even in sales like
i'll give you an example
instagram if i want to find leads today
i can send 100 dms a day to network with
people
40 years ago if i'm in sales i'm doing
real estate i have to have quarters in
my car and if i'm driving an hour to
person so man they don't pick up and
it's raining i got to find a local
you know a phone booth and wait for
somebody to finish their calls
yeah i mean it's a joke today to make
money i've got news for you
the generation behind the millennials
my experience the interns we've had they
are work horses gen z
gen z yeah they do and work
and work and they're serious about it
they save money
they're they're they're just they have a
different mindset
and i'm not too worried about this
country's future i'm not
because i know that there's an entire
generation coming up
that has that that will
weather and withstand as long as they're
not trading day trading yeah
um but there's another generation that
that does have a good old-fashioned
work ethic and i'm i'm hopeful all right
yeah what's the 80 20 uh concept pareto
theory
p-r-e-d-o predo i think is it a t or a d
okay
so here's where i'm going with this yeah
um
we all have decisions to make okay we
all have 24 hours right we're all gonna
sleep you know
six to eight hours some sleep four some
sleep eight some sleep ten
but what are you doing with the the rest
of your day some people choose to spend
their mornings
on a with us on a podcast learning
getting smarter
some people are reading some people at
night kai reads 10 books a day
some people do that some people in their
spare time choose to
slack off you know smoke weed play video
games
bs you know it's also about what you do
with your time so there's i'm sure
a correlation with the 55 who are
investing in america
who are reading or watching podcasts
like this versus the person who does
their nine to five they get off they get
their paycheck
you know they smoke a joint they sit at
home they do nothing they play video
games they don't work out
there has to be a correlation with that
but i think the corona virus is going to
end that i really do
it's going to end what the what i think
the coronavirus is going to change the
way
work is approached i don't think the
nine to fivers got too long of a life
expectancy in the workforce
i think that the coronavirus has
expedited automation
like put it into hyperdrive so i i mean
it's
living through it too very powerful what
you just said by the way
did you hear what you just said so so so
you're saying that nine to fiver
is not gonna have a long lifespan and
what coronavirus did
automation is gonna expedite that
process look if you're joe q
human resources manager and you've got
all these people working remotely right
now
all you have to do is pull pull up a
spreadsheet and you just look at their
numbers and you're like this person's
productive oh i always thought this
person was a slacker
look they are and it's objective yep and
you just go
delete and that's what but but now we
see i mean you know
if a working mother who's got three kids
doing three
you know three different grades doing
you know different curriculums
and she can still produce because who
knows if she's up at two o'clock in the
morning when everybody
when everything finally settles down but
all i'm saying is
that this is going to be something that
separates the wheat from the chaff
i almost said something different but
yeah but but and it will be a game
changer in how
the workforce itself evolves into its
new self small businesses in america
used to employ
lots of people human capital
now people don't want to interact as
much with humans so even small
businesses are automating
so it is time to realize
i'm back on my china soapbox it is time
to realize that they're inventing the
next generation of technology
and we need to get busy and make sure
that we are in front of them
[Music]
you